hallo leute wir suchen aktuell nach
neuen teammitgliedern für unser easy
german team und für inselsysteme
und da wir hier auf youtube eine ganz
große community haben dachten wir nutzen
wir mal diese plattform um euch davon zu
erzählen und vielleicht gibt es ja
jemand von euch oder ihr kennt jemanden
der für diese stellen in frage kommt und
zwar sind wir ja ein relativ kleines
team wir produzieren hier videos aus
berlin
aber in den letzten jahren sind wir auch
weiter gewachsen
wir produzieren mittlerweile nicht nur
videos sondern auch einen podcast
dreimal pro woche
und wir haben einen mitgliedschaft
programm viele von euch sind schon dabei
und wir lernen online zusammen und haben
eine kleine community gegründet und zur
unterstützung unseres teams suchen wir
ab sofort einen deutschlehrer oder eine
deutschlehrerin und jemanden der sich
mit finanzen auskennt wenn ihr also ein
deutschlehrer oder in der
deutschlehrerin seite und auch schon
erfahrung hatte unterrichten
idealerweise auch schon erfahrung darin
eigene lerninhalte zu entwickeln euch
vielleicht auch ein bisschen mit
digitalen medien auskennt dann schaut
euch mal unsere stellenbeschreibung an
die wir hier und verlinken und falls ihr
jemand seit der sich so richtig mit
vielen manchen auskennt und lust hat
unser team als finance und partnership
manager zu unterstützen also uns auch
dabei zu helfen mit anderen zusammen
partnerschaften einzugehen
unsere ganzen finanzen in ordnung zu
bringen so schlimm ist es nicht aber es
ist ein bisschen arbeit dann guckt euch
mal diese stellenbeschreibung an
das sind die zwei positionen die wir
aktuell im team suchen um unsere arbeit
zu verbessern um unser team zu stärken
und wir würden uns sehr freuen wenn ihr
jemanden kennt wenn ihr vielleicht eine
total tolle deutschlehrerin habt oder
einen totalen tollen deutschlehrer und
dass dieser person empfiehlt und mal
bescheid sagt das easy därmen team sucht
nach verstärkungen
und damit nicht genug falls diese beiden
stellen nicht so gut zu euch passen dann
schaut auch mal bei unserem
partners ii längst vorbei wie ihr wisst
arbeiten wir sehr eng mit zielen das ist
eine deutsch lernplattform und eine app
wie auch deutsch unterrichtet auf eine
strukturierte art und weise und dort
suchen wir aktuell nach leuten und zwar
nach einem ruby on rails developer ich
habe mir sagen lassen dass es eine
programmiersprache und nach einem
projekt developer falls ihr erfahrungen
habt wir suchen dort auch jemanden mit
berufserfahrung schon einigen jahren
dann schaut auch mal hier unten denn
diese stelle haben wir auch verlinkt und
zu guter letzt falls ihr ein spanisch
lehrer oder spanisch lehrerin seit oder
ein französisch lehrer oder eine
französisch lehrerin und auch noch in
berlin lebt dann könnt ihr uns helfen
denn wir möchten bald sieling auch in
anderen sprachen staaten nämlich in
französisch und spanisch um genau zu
sein
all diese angebote findet ihr unten in
unserer infobox und wir würden euch
waren wir würden uns wahnsinnig freuen
wenn ihr unsere arbeiten möchte und lust
habt dabei zu sein in unserem
internationalen team dann schaut mal
vorbei auf unsere seiten wie sie den
i-punkt jobs und sie weg und kommt slash
jobs und vielleicht arbeiten wir ja bald
zusammen dankeschön fürs zuschauen und
bis bald